Now that we have an extra column, our variable and
our data frame, we can create a histogram of it.
This histogram reveals that most households buy one or two
yogurts at a time. To dive deeper into our yogurt
prices and household behavior. Let's investigate the price over time
in more detail. This is where our Facebook data was
deficient. In this data set, we can examine changes in
prices because we have data on the same households over time.
So, now I want you to use your
knowledge of scatter plots and over-plotting to create
an appropriate visualization. Your visualization should be a
scatter plot of price versus time. Now, there's no
right answer here, so just create a plot
that's sensible and that allows you to see the
data. You can assess your code and your
plot with what we did in the solution video.